let's jump to the story from usa9
coy griffin barred from public office
for ins in sec insurrectionary conduct a
new mexico judge ruled coy griffin was
disqualified from holding office under
section 3 of the 14th amendment so they
finally got one
they have been trying democrats to get
people barred from holding office under
the 14th amendment for being
insurrection for for insurrection and
now a judge has actually done it
is barring him from office i think
they're removing him right in a judgment
issued tuesday tuesday morning new
mexico district court judge francis j
matthew ruled griffin was permanently
enjoined and prohibited from seeking or
holding any federal or state position as
defined by the 14th amendment to the u.s
constitution that includes his current
position as a commissioner in otero
county new mexico the judge wrote
this is crazy stuff well this had
nothing to do and again i think they
need to understand what insurrection
actually means but go back to what he
actually did he was the founder of
cowboys for trump
and that's really what this is about
this is continual witch hunt and going
after trump trump trump maga maga
you're seeing this in every single thing
that's playing out and it's really about
what president trump told a long time
ago which is that they're not after me
they're after you i'm just in the way
yep
this is i i don't know if this will be
upheld i mean i imagine that'll get
appealed as it should yeah but the idea
that they keep levying these attacks i'm
just like guys guys
civil war
come on
come on they're not trying to win
elections now with stuff like this
they're just trying to find a judge
who's willing to bang a gavel and say
okay fine we removed him they tried
doing it to marjorie taylor greene
that's right they uh they tried doing it
to uh madison cawthorne who else did
they go after on this one obviously well
and they were successful with the
establishment's help of eliminating
madison but that was through the primary
100 they primary amount i'm talking
about
when you can't even win a primary they
go to a judge and say just bang your
gavel and say he can't be in office and
the judge went okay they used to do that
and seize people's property then they
were rebellions and revolts that shay's
rebellion was about them seizing their
land
i don't know
also taking away their ability to run
for office
man it doesn't feel right so i'll tell
you one of the things that i i probably
have people who disagree with me on this
but you know it's like i talk about you
know my my mom and dad they both have
you know a very colorful past and and
they've committed mistakes and and
they're they've have felony because of
drug use and and all the other things
like this but you know denying people
who are felons from their right to vote
you're essentially eliminating their
voice and and i just don't agree with
this you know it's like the idea that
you know i have two children i was 17
and seven-year-old and you know it's
like my seven-year-old doing something
wrong and then after i i give him his
punishment me carrying that for the rest
of his life i mean that's really what it
feels like and you know this is the type
of thing that i just really push back
against
where you're continually you know
basically levied as a criminal as a
result of a single crime no matter what
your actual punishment was and the
elimination of your voice or the banging
of a gavel ending your capabilities to
serve our nation i mean
at some stage this really we have to
start looking at our justice system and
how that works can they stop people from
running for local elections too with
this stuff
it is a local election that's what this
is an outside commission
for like a federal force or a state
governance force to tell you you can't
govern and your local community is way
antithetical to the united states in new
mexico it's un-american i mean it truly
is un-american i mean the idea that one
if you commit a crime you can never vote
again you can never have a voice again
you can you know with a bang of a gavel
you can never ever serve in office again
i mean the this is
the the issue is
this was a
a really stupid article in the section
in the in the 14th amendment
because it was obvious and i suppose the
founding fathers of the foresight but
you know 80 years later they did not so
much it's obvious that
how do you define insurrection against
the government yeah right george
washington waged an insurrection against
the king the point is happy insurrection
it's january 6th insurrection the the
feds look there's some people who are
currently charged with seditious
conspiracy i really don't believe but
you know the funniest part do you know
who the people who are indicted are
people like john earl sullivan who is a
very well-known blm antagonist who
basically weighs a
false flag
he did have an indictment he did yes he
did oh wow and they did nothing with it
this is the same guy by the way that cnn
paid for the murder of ashley babbitt's
you know footage he was indicted for
january for being on there in the
capital correct and and he was actually
in a false flag operation wearing all
maggot gear even though he's a blm
antagonist i mean this this is
we we have to really start understanding
either we're moving past this or we're
going to do a proper not this nonsense
j6 unselect committee where they
wouldn't even allow true patriots in a
bipartisan fashion like congressman jim
jordan or congressman jim banks to sit
on this you know they picked the other
two democrats kenzinger and cheney who
are both gone now but but the whole
point is is that you know we need proper
justice you know we need real
investigations you know there is no
doubt in my mind that there's a false
flag operation there's no doubt in my
mind that there was some type of an fbi
kind of insider you know deal going on
here i mean we
we have to start looking at this and
really investigate if we're going to
investigate this investigate the real
way not from a partisan political witch
hunt but from a real we want to get the
answers you got to win
but you and that's partisan publicly got
to win in november and then not only do
they have to win but you have to win
leverage over the you know establishment
republican types who are going to just
sit on their hands and go well hold on
now well you know what's funny about
this case compared to
someone else so this guy this will stick
with him forever can't run for office
he's an insurrectionist but if you were
in kenosha that night and you burnt down
15 stores and you looted stuff and you
you can run for office and you can just
say you were out there and this is
exactly what i talked about you
because you believe deeply in these
issues and black lives matter well it's
it's mostly peaceful protests yeah and
so so one guy is is an insurrectionist
and who walked through the capitol
building again obeying those red velvet
ropes we talked to the podium guy
i know he's a lectern that was great but
everyone calls him podium guy and his
story it's like he's a dude who walked
into a building befuddled and kind of
ignorantly and then moved a thing and
went to prison for it meanwhile you have
people who romped about set fire to
buildings throw brick throw brick
through murdered david dorne who was the
former uh uh law enforcement
guy though well they did but my point is
though is that at the exact same time
that seattle minneapolis new york
portland you had chop you had all these
things going on which were complete
lawlessness violent rioting looting of
of tens of millions of dollars if not
more murders rapes all these things were
going on they justified those as
protests and you had the left who were
inciting this saying like maxwell maxine
waters who were saying well you should
get in the face of every single one of
your political opponents or you know you
have the others the vice president
herself who actually created the
minneapolis you know foundation fund or
whatever that was the bail fund
i mean the idea that they're actually
promoting this
you know and then all of a sudden they
want to go ahead and just because it's
conservatives on one side or or
democrats on the other they want to go
ahead and try and re-label this or
re-you know identify this this this is
the type of thing that america doesn't
need yeah one of the things that also
bothered me about the biden speech just
connecting the two for a second was the
amount of uh the straw men and i i
firmly believe that straw men are an
essential tool of the democrat party but
multiple times he kept talking about how
these mega people who were calling for
political violence i've never heard for
anyone except for maxine waters i've
never heard anyone call for i've never
i've listened to a lot of trump speeches
i follow a lot of these folks i do this
this stuff for a living i have i'm
trying to find someone who has called
for political violence and yet he gave
that that remark
so comfortably so callously that many of
these maga republicans and then he went
on fantastic terrorism
there is no time ever for political
violence and everyone collapsed the left
says and even said go home peacefully
who the left says donald trump
speaking out in the way he does is
stochastic terrorism yeah that was my
favorite what that means is
that when trump says i think this thing
is a bad thing he's secretly calling on
his followers to go and attack that
exactly when joe biden comes out and
says they're extremists a threat to our
country and they embrace violence what
would you call that but this goes back
to the old idea that remember when the
king
he actually comes forward and says can
no one rid me of this petulant priest
and all of a sudden they go out and
murder the priest and say oh well you
were actually the reasoning for this
because you actually indirectly said
this right this is what they're trying
to refer to when they try and say this
about president trump but president
trump wasn't indirectly hinting at
anything he very clearly said
let us all go home peacefully but i
don't mean i don't mean that speech i'm
talking about in general yeah no i i'm
with you i'm just trying to say that i
think that's what the left is trying to
say though is that he somehow you know
made this into charles manson for
instance he told his followers go eth it
up go mess them up you know to the and
then they went and they killed people
manson never said go kill people he just
said go mess it up trump didn't say go
mess it up no he didn't tell them to go
hurt anything he said he did it
peacefully and cheering some politicians
he was pretty specific about it being
peaceful too correct i just don't
understand and i also just again i have
a great dislike for the establishment
media i just find it funny that he makes
those straw men comments so comfortably
and yet no one seems curious to say well
mr president could you give us an
example of who is calling for political
that is a very good and basic question
the next time he ever speaks to the
media we're going on 220 days where he
hasn't spoken to the media but that is a
great question you decried mega
republicans uh um calling for political
violence could you cite an example of a
maga republican calling for political
revival of course not but no one will
ever ask him that question they will ask
him like mr president when you're eating
vanilla ice cream how does that make
your tummy feel
the president right now the office has
no responsibility to reply to any
questions come on which is a problem
well he doesn't take questions and
that's the whole point he goes up there
he reads from teleprompters as his
handlers tell him and then he shuffles
off and and you know mysteriously shakes
hands of people who don't actually exist
i gotta i i got some questions so you're
likely you're coming into congress right
you won the primary that's basically the
race it's an r plus district so you got
it you think right well i don't take
anything for granted but yes i i it oh
gosh
politician listen to that
i just don't believe in taking my
it would be the first time you you've
held you'd hold federal office i've
never run in my life what do you what do
you what do you want to do what do you
think you can do once you get in well i
want to bring awareness to the real
issues i want to actually bring real
solutions to things i want to understand
the fact that the america first agenda
doesn't make you a racist or a xenophobe
when you just want to secure your
borders protect your children you know
get our military back to its original
strength stop these endless wars stop
looking at the insider trading that's
going on within politics call balls and
strikes on both sides i mean look we
have to understand that the deep state
in swamp you know whether that's left or
right are all involved and we know this
we have to stop the corruption we have
to actually identify what the corruption
is that's why you know in mind very much
like president trump like i'm donating
100 of my salary back into my actual
district selected by my constituents to
a woman child or veteran charity the
other thing is that myself my wife and
anyone who wants to work in my office
can not buy selling trade stocks while
we're in office this is not about
political enrichment this is about
serving the people and no one
understands about serving the people
more than the actual military who went
out was willing to die when they swore
that oath and our oath doesn't expire
just because we take off that uniform
you know this is really about making
sure that we get back to what it is to
be a true constitutionalist be a true
conservative understand physical
responsibility understand the
significance of energy and dependence
and knowing that we cannot you know i'm
a business owner i am about job creation
and guess what government doesn't create
jobs they stifle they over regulate and
they actually prevent jobs we need to
empower the private sector we need to
understand the tenth amendment and
understanding state and individual
rights these are the things that i stand
for and at the end of the day i'm an
employee of the seventh district of
florida
i am not the one who gets elected by the
people and then thinks that the party
somehow put me in office
so i'm all about and i and i have a
couple of bills that i want to pass in
my first hundred days and one of the
bills that i really like is called the
publishing house bill one of the things
i want to look at is that i don't
believe in impeding upon state rights
and governor ron desantis has done the k
through right parental rights bill which
i think is phenomenal but i think from a
federal issue one of the things we
should be looking at
holding the publishing houses
accountable like the mcgraw-hills or
anyone else who is intentionally
publishing pornographic or inappropriate
material with the intent of distribution
to underage inappropriate material to
children that are the age of six and
seven years old we also need to start
thinking about the days when i grew up
where if i went to my grandmother would
drop me off to the movies and give me 20
and i'd have to go in and they'd say how
do you oh i'm 13. okay here's the movies
that you can buy and here's the ratings
why can't we put books that have actual
ratings on it a g rating a pg-13 rating
etc so that our parents who work all day
long who don't have time to proofread
all these books can go ahead and say you
know what this is within your age group
now i'm not saying we should ban books
you can publish as many books as you
want
but i am saying that you should not and
cannot basically distribute these to an
actual under underage or youth in our
library and if you do it should be a
felonious offense you should register as
a sex predator for the rest of your life
are you talking about imagery or are you
talking about both descriptors so i i it
doesn't matter even if you're trying to
make it an anime or you're trying to get
a cartoon i mean look at genderqueer for
example which actually shows oral sex
and that's supposed to be third grade
appropriate if they're describing it
that would be
like you don't want like even textual
descriptions but my whole point is that
whether you actually write it in text or
you actually show it in you know the
figure it's the exact same thing so my
question is uh there are parts of the
bible that are explicit and talk about
sex
should that be restricted from schools
but having already banned the bible from
from being in schools i mean i had a
young kid the other day for example he
was 14 years old and he said you know
what i wish i could have i wish i just
had the right to be able to go ahead and
pray and to be able to read the bible in
school and he said my teachers have
actually banned me from being able to do
so you know
outside outside of the fact that they've
all read they already do for the most
part restrict bibles do you think that
in the same context the bible would be
inappropriate for young kids to read no
i don't think in the bible i mean i mean
i i see
but i think the whole point is though
shouldn't that be up to the parents to
be able to go ahead and make these
things shouldn't shouldn't it actually
be parental rights and not actually just
the teachers unions who are saying this
is the curriculum we're going to speech
and again going back to how joe biden
calls you know everyone who's maga
america first extremist now you've got
these actual teachers unions who are
actually saying that if you're a parent
who doesn't want certain things to be
taught to your children you're now a
domestic terrorist i mean this this is
the type of thing and you know this is
only one of many bills i mean one of the
biggest bills i i want to look at right
now is the banning of you know purchased
by foreigners to you know buy up our
farmlands especially china i mean this
is something that's really important to
me because we have to understand this
economic resource warfare and the fact
that our farmlands and our actual you
know residences are being bought up by
china russia and other nations who are
trying to stop affordability and
availability of housing who are trying
to prevent the actual you know growth of
our actual domestic products when it
comes to our agricultural sector things
like this i mean there's a lot indiana
just passed this law actually last year
where they actually ban foreign
ownership of their farmlands you know
there's so many things that we have to
write on this ship and that's you know
part of the reason why i'm running is to
try and make sure that we're
prioritizing america over foreigners
american energy over foreign oil our
borders over ukrainian borders our
veterans over illegals and our children
over teachers if you could give a
congressman something
well i just wanted to wrap up that point
on uh the the explicit nature of you
know explicit depictions in the bible
the meme uh versus ezekiel 23 20 that
talks about um the size of the man that
the woman liked and the emissions of the
men and things like that and i think you
know my view on it is
parents should be absolutely especially
with with the bible like teaching their
kids about what they find to be
appropriate the issue with the schools
is they're keeping it a secret from the
parents well but sunday school taught
something totally different than what
you learned when you were so i remember
going to school for example or going to
uh when i was younger sunday school
where
my grandparents would go into the main
hall and then we kind of went into the
children's area and we would learn
things like dave and goliath or you know
you know it should be up to the parent
when their actual child are taught these
things i mean it should be that's the
whole point of the birds and the bee
stories should be taught by the parents
it should never be taught when i when i
grew up look there is no i hate when
people say there's an over sexualization
of children no no there should be no
sexualization of children that should be
left up to the parental rights that
should be left up to the actual parents
on when they feel that their children
are ready to hear certain things this is
why for example that when i would deploy
to them you know to combat i wouldn't
explain what my job is or what i've done
in war to my wife the same way i would
explain to my six-year-old for example
yeah you know there's a time and true
issue is when the teacher does without
your consent or knowledge and keeps it a
secret and says don't tell your parents
like if a teacher went to a kid and said
you know your father is a murderer and
he goes around and he does this that or
otherwise and they don't tell your
parents i told you this is a problem the
parents have right to know so anyway i i
ask because i think you know for for
some of this material that they want to
show kids
yeah when the parents deem it
appropriate with at their discretion not
the school's doing it in secret keeping
it from the parents be it any kind of
explicit depiction see and i think that
we shouldn't even have this in the
school system because then no matter how
woke the teacher is they don't have the
materials in the schools to actually
teach for them to begin with
and that's why i looked at the
publishing house bills for the exact
reason but i mean you know
again that's that's why i asked the
question like do you think the bible
should be out of public schools i don't
actually but then the bible has
depictions and it is no understood but
it should be one of those things where i
think that the individual parents should
have a right to build again i i go back
to what i was talking about with the
sunday school versus sitting in the
actual main hall you know you learn two
different things other materials that
are like work or whatever i'm not
telling you that should be taught by
these teachers but should that be
available for students if they wanted to
go and you know read the bible during
their library time or whatever the case
may be why shouldn't it be i think the
bible is also sometimes there are parts
of the bible that are age-appropriate
right there are some explicit parts of
the bible that doesn't mean you banned
the book but that doesn't mean you have
to teach it to to the five-year-olds
even right we don't we don't you know
but the five-year-olds know that jesus
carried the cross but they don't have to
watch the passion of the christ right i
mean like you can get the point across
my point without having to get into like
well well you know the nail actually
went through like whoa whoa
if the parents say
i would like my this teacher to teach my
child about the bible
which includes all of it in terms you
know we can edit selective parts out
there's nothing wrong with that well in
the same way because the kid's not
appropriate same would be true for
inappropriate you know explorations of
you know like like i don't want to say
explicitly gender queers there's
questions about ideology but a book that
includes you know coming of age sexual
discussions you could argue it should be
available for the teachers but they
should avoid those topics without unless
the parents consent right
um
like they can read around it and say i'm
going to read to you about billy going
for a joyride in his dad's car it was a
problem or the story of johnny who
fought his bully yeah but we're not
going to read the part where billy goes
on his first then every kid in the class
like we got to get the first date part
yo it's all about that first part i
don't understand the moral difference
then between allowing them to just grab
the bible and and laugh and point to the
depictions of the horse-sized male girth
you know what i mean can you show me
where in the bible that actually is
ezekiel 23 20 no but my point is that
there is no actual like photo of of
these that's why
text depictions were well i think that
definitely has to do with something when
it comes to age group obviously i mean i
don't see that many uh second graders
running to the bible uh you know
unfortunately but i mean when you talk
about when you're getting greater but
here's why but here's my point though we
did when i was everybody
yeah but my reason in saying that is is
that when you have something which is
like genderqueer for example which is in
cartoon fashion
right you are actually building that the
idea of trying to
uh
encourage some of the youth to be able
to go and at least look at the photos of
these things
because images
three-year-old can see the imagery that
that's yes i agree with that right which
is why i'm asking if like textual
depictions are you know comparable to
image but i i i think it's fairly
obvious images can be substantially
wrong i'm also curious as to what the
lesson is that the teacher is trying to
get across like and i feel gross i'm not
going to lie it feels like you're
committing a crime thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there